non
il se nomme 2007 et cinq autres ont un
type qui passe en premier vous êtes fait
avoir je vais demander un public est
chauffé donc vous allez tous vous lever
me sertic lourdes salves incombe ensuite
ans et parle 30 1 l'europe c'est parti
on y va allez hop hop hop
non je déconne je viens vous présenter
ce soir ma vision du temps pour moi donc
le temps ce verbe à ce titre de monteur
et je viens de vous présenter ce soir je
suis et pourquoi le temps de se perd pas
je suis coach sportif mais pour se
suffire pour expliquer donc je vais
prendre aux yeux l'image du mois de mai
baignoire mais j'ai un sac visible et un
grimoire ici vous diront s'ils avaient
sorti de ma thèse
on va le faire comme ça on avait un peu
de la poussière des pensées négatives
qui collent toujours appelé trop
statique et commençant je me suis dit
quoi de mieux pour vous puissiez le
connaître un peu mieux que de max et sur
mes vieux bulletin scolaire en seconde
place sur le départ prono logique on est
parti la maternelle
alors qu'est ce qu'on dit surtout à
cette époque élèves agréable les joueurs
se libèrent au dessus comme ça donc les
damphousse
on y va tranquillement écoles
élémentaires c'est bien les dents
repoussé alors qu'est ce qu'on dit sur
toi maintenant et l'âme intelligent né
manque d'attention par moments la
battait je suis un petit peu comme un
bruit surtout le sport surtout le sport
ou en effet ça va aller allez passons
tranquillement prochaine étape le
collège oui pour le sport se voit la
natation constitua de la compétition
mais au niveau scolaire alors qu'est ce
qu'on dit élève intelligent mais manque
d'attention
ouais bon à part pour le sport oui comme
d'habitude tu sais ce que tu veux faire
déjà plus tard prof de sport d'accord
oui moi ça se comprend bon ben je dois
quand même hein il a glissé qui arrive
voilà nous voir qu'est-ce qu'on dit au
lycée élève moyen que de faire ouais ont
heureusement il ya toujours le souvent
pour rattraper la moyenne
qu'est-ce qui a su rester polis
mission pour quota de la compétition de
natation 16-17 collage colle à la peau
c'est chiant oui c'est stressant la
compétition et empêcher bon le pack avec
la moyenne
la moyenne et un sommet oui bon allez ça
passe comme excuse
continuons tranquillement la faculté à
bâle a déjà c'est mieux ça reste moyen
mais c'est mieux parce que 15 déjà où je
peux je peux donc m'éclater en staps
faire des études sur le le domaine qui
me plaît bien compris c'est le sport et
grâce au staff j'ai pu donc découvrir la
discipline qui me passionnait par
différents domaines et ça m'a permis
d'aboutir à cette envie l'envi de faire
le coach ambulants non spécialisés
natation petit jeu de mots je commence à
donner des cours de natation
mais ce n'est pas encore le coach
sportif que je souhaiterais je
souhaitais hâte à cette époque et que je
suis actuellement le coach ambulances
etc le départ c'est les cours natation
fait des bulles et je me dis qu'il m'en
faut plus si je suis ressorti de la
faculté avec un vent important en tête
c'est celui là sion
c'est beaucoup c'est en staps et la
transversalité sont des études reee qui
nous permet de découvrir énormément de
domaines et je me suis dit je veux
devenir mon propre patron il me faut
donc être un peu plus d'expérience je me
décide d'en décider
on a un travail faute et a gagné cinq
autres je ne viens donc vendeur
d'articles sportifs dans le ciel que je
ne connais pas mais beaucoup beaucoup
d'expérience beaucoup de convivialité ça
me permet vraiment découverte des
facettes nécessaires pour gérer une
entreprise et comment il allait falloir
que je me prenne par la suite
trois ans après donc avec cette
expérience pour devenir le coach sportif
que je veux être je veux associer
préparateur physique et préparateur
mental mon préparateur physique et
mental rien à voir avec le fromage en
termes de transversalité donc je me
demande qu'est ce qu'il ya de plus
important sur quoi il faudrait que je me
base je suis parti sur le temps la
perception du temps le temps réel que
vous pouvez voir symbolisée ici et le
temps perçu sur lequel nous allons
commencer la belle mèche d'encours elle
qui nous fait partir l'an des bouts de
première deuxième et après on se laisse
un peu détaché du temps réel et le temps
vient influencer nos émotions et en
défense sans totalement compris mais pas
à s'étendre jamais
septembre pour pouvoir tout faire et
qu'on a toutes les connexions c'est pas
possible
mais faut le temps même si des fois il
nous paraît bien trop long bien trop
dure à supporter de le voir avec des
événements
les jours mais on va pas s'attarder là
dessus moi je vous amène outils de
gestion du stress justement comment
sortir de cet état du temps perçu voilà
j'ai cherché la victime à l'époque et je
me suis arrêté sur cette phrase le temps
ne se perd pas ce n'est pas la négation
de je perds mon temps c'est plus
linverse du temps c'est de l'argent
une connexion qui pour moi est malsaine
entre le temps et l'argent savez vous
qui a dit cette phrase parce que
quelqu'un on est à 1 à 10 mai
alors
c'est abdullah messieurs c'est pas jamin
franklin l'appellera danton benji paraît
qu'on est tous de la même famille tantôt
mendy pour vous messieurs aujourd'hui
voilà ce que ce que ce lien avec
l'argent n'a fait ressortir qu'une
grosse entière surtout à l'époque donc
vous découvrez les joies de l'expérience
dans la vie professionnelle dans le
domaine privé impression de jouer à
pacman en euroland donc
et à ce petit jeu là il faut avoir la
passion de bachmann de pouvoir et ré
indéfiniment dans les couloirs à
grappiller le moindre petit euro en
phase retour n'est fait attention aux
euro qui sont qui vous font face peuvent
vous mangez donc que tout mon âge et
ajoie bachmann mêmes sensations sauf que
là c'est nous les pac man qui essayons
désespérément de croquer des petits
bouts d'euros plus en plus mais
généralement voilà ce que ça provoque du
stress du stress qui peut même nous
amener à la colère et pas forcément des
grosses colères des petits trucs à
loudun des fois mais c'est quelqu'un de
sérieux en voulait 6 d'arrivée
de retard le pari non retard au boulot
d'essayer d'être à l'heure et on se
retrouve dans les embouteillages qu'on
n'a pas prévu là d'un seul coup mamie en
pole position dans sa voiture des lances
dimas
le feu passe au vert
une demi seconde c'est cool et on est
déjà enfin que la saône et politiquement
ma vie avance et moi sommes amis à
calais et oui bah oui si on l'avait
passé ces mamies si on n'avait pas
klaxonné après elle aurait peut-être
démarrer surya rivés à leur boulot vous
auriez pas été stressé par d'autres
patrons elle vous soit répandre colère
on rentre on chez vous le soir quelque
chose d'important lorsqu on est stressé
en colère à faire cette semaine des
petits post it comme ceci dans un peu
partout pour ne pas oublier de respirer
vous avoue le post-it il faut surtout la
voir dans la tête je n'ai pas oublier de
respirer c'est important et ça tombe
bien dans le sport gaza il faut pas
oublier de respirer
mais attention petit piège le sport
hocine voit bien que le domaine de la
compétition a été contaminé par ce lien
temps argent
voilà ce que ça donne oui au second
degré cette phrase est bien une phrase
de motivation qui nous permet donc de
nous dépasser
en traduisant non c'est pas de douleur
pas de gain pris au premier degré c'est
déjà moins marrant dit que on peut pas
obtenir quoi que ce soit sans avoir mal
problématique
moi je vous propose de vous reconnecter
avec vous même grâce au temps ce n'est
pas le temps de se perd pas en fermant
les yeux
instant et on re en cliquant sur cette
icône gagner nicole une icône de réseau
social à l'intérieur de voix l'intérieur
de votre cerveau prenez un petit instant
visualiser ce bouton parce que la vie
c'est gagné il n'y a pas besoin de
chercher plus si vous chercher le
bonheur vous ça c'est important
la vie c'est gagner il n'y a pas besoin
de passer par les phases de douleurs +1
point compte que ça pouvait s'épanouir
petite phrase bien sympa connaissez vous
ce monsieur quelqu'un peut dire son nom
exactement
l'être humain a besoin de temps pour lui
a besoin de temps pour ne rien faire
rien faire quelque part on ne fait
jamais rien pour rappel on essaie de ne
pas oublier de respirer dans quelque
part on a toujours une activité
cérébrale au moins pour maintenir celui
du momment vital que nous dit aussi
cherabi donc cette pathologie du travail
ou forcément quelqu'un qui ne fait rien
et d'un fainéant
encore une fois quelque chose de
problématique qu'on devrait pouvoir
dépasser se reconnecter avec nous mêmes
pour se rendre compte que dans nos têtes
malgré qu'on essaye par en faisant du
square du yoga de la méditation de se
vider la tête
pensez à oublier c'est faux c'est
d'avançon ne peut pas oublier qu'il faut
apprendre à faire avec le film de la
pensée se rencontrent en plus
l'absolu ne peut pas exister nous invite
prenez une main basse et là dans l'air
profitez vous pouvez vous éventé en même
temps santé si l'air et des vides il y
aurait pas le fait chier on ne pourrait
pas bien il fait chaud à saint denis là
aujourd'hui pourraient pas profiter de
sa main pour ressentir cette fraîcheur
et bien le temps de se perdre à ces
outils qui m'a permis de ressentir cette
fraîcheur dans la tête et c'est pas ce
monsieur qui dira le contraire
bon il a l'air comme ça un peu
léthargique mais ce n'est pas un breguet
enfermé dans un laboratoire scientifique
on a tous privé de ses droits pour
pouvoir l'exploiter
non ce monsieur ce monsieur si quelqu'un
de connu est ce que quelqu'un sait qui
est ce monsieur au fond exactement s'il
ya des références à citer ce monsieur
vous pouvez dire vous les douaniers de
l'altruisme ce mec et c'est un super
héros c'est super en batik et il a fait
avancer la science dans le morceau
domaine de la méditation
cet homme à l'alluré léthargique qui la
lie à l'herbe est un ferment comme ça
grâce aux petites électrodes qui ont été
collées sur la tête on a pu se rendre
compte sans entrer dans les détails
parce que c'est assez compliqué mais en
gros ce monsieur pense comme il avait ça
va aussi vite alors dû pour le
stéréotype je suis assis je fais rien on
repassera la méditation c'est au
contraire le mouvement où notre cerveau
est atteint
l'optimum de ses capacités comment
pouvoir se reconnecter à ça donc entre
temps perçu le temps réel un petit coup
de mathématiques
donc pour vous prouver que pour nous
grâce à l'expérience on peut développer
à la réflexion qu'on peut se faire grâce
à ça on est plus fort que l'on pierrick
on est plus fort que ce qui est soi
disant forcément comme ça le théorique
nous dit gang si on additionne un
nombreux à supérieur à 0 est un nombreux
b inférieures à zéro donc négatif dans
le cas où à est supérieur à la valeur
s'il donnait pas de souci en obtient un
résultat positif
dans le cas inverse si v elle valeur
absolue de bay superior on obtient un
résultat négatif basque est magnifique
c'est magnifique avec les expériences
c'est que quel que soit le cas mais
lorsque l'expérience négative et à l'air
plus important que tout ce qu'on a
accumulé comme positif et bien on
obtient du positif et c'est ça qui est
merveilleux
comment faire ceci donc se reconnecter
au temps réel de temps réel on va faire
un petit définition rapide qu'est ce
qu'il nous faut surtout à quoi ça sert
établir une chronologie est ce qu'il
nous faut pour établir cette chronologie
une fois un instant d'origine et
humidité constante pour visualiser une
image et sa dent dans la tête
voilà qu'est ce qu'on peut voir plus ou
moins sûr mais tu es dans nos têtes
voilà ce que c'est on est sur une
échelle on regarde on le sait les
barreaux du futur on est dans un ciel il
fait beau aujourd'hui quelques nuages de
penser chargées négativement vous
vivement vous les laissez passer
tranquillement si on regarde on va
passer une échelle magic emmené dans
notre cerveau de la pensée c'est là la
même chose en dessous des pensées qui
s'écoule et on peut voir le barreau de
mémoire personnelle en haut en bas et le
plus important celui qu'on oublie c'est
le barreau du milieu le barreau du
présent le barreau donc qui nous permet
de transformer toutes nos expériences
négatives en expérience positive et
s'épanouir je pouvais pas conclure non
sans un petit combat un clin d'oeil à
tonton benji casser un peu à couper un
peu l'air sous ses pieds donc finir
là-dessus même six ans donc que cette
phrase ait une origine d'un proverbe
chinois
il ya des sources qui disons que tonton
badji a dit ceci tu me dis j'oublie tu
mens scène je me souviens tu m'applique
j'apprends sortie l'après montech avec
le plus d'influencé positive de ce que
je viens de vous dire le temps de ce cap
à j'ai besoin de vous préciser que c'est
mon outil c'est ma vision du temps que
je me suis appliqué à mal par an
montaren dit croire réellement et
pouvoir transmettre le message
si vous savez parle vous pouvez repartir
avec emballé nous et c'est cadeau c'est
gratuit mais sachez qu'il va être
important que vous puissiez donc vous
approprier cette phrase trouvé le moyen
de vous l'appliquez à vous même le temps
de superba je vais vous rendez vous
remercier d'être venus m'écouter toqués
aujourd'hui sur ce thème durel pour vous
donc d'une banque dont ka k
temps un capital riche important moi
cette phase donc j'ai investi dedans et
j'ai fini par aboutir à la méditation
sportif qui est la méthode que je
développe en tant que sportif
aujourd'hui est donc n'oubliez pas le
temps de cette richesse qui au moins
elle prendra le relais voilà vous
remercie vous plus vous faites